Speaker 1: A an indented face of Joe Biden has
triggered medical disclosures. And we have now
learned that Joe Biden is using a CPAP machine,
not CPAP. Very different thing, a CPAP machine
at night to treat sleep apnea. You know, the the
images that came out. It's not even really that
clear. But if you look at the image I have up
on the screen, if you look at Joe Biden's right
cheek, there are these two parallel lines. It's
sort of an indent. If you trace a line between
his ear lobe to the sort of upper lip, you see one
of those lines and then maybe about half to three
quarters of an inch. Below that, you see another
parallel line, an indentation of sorts. This is
now triggered a release from the White House about
Joe Biden's health. Joe Biden reports CNN has
started using a CPAP machine to treat sleep apnea
after indentations from straps were seen on both
side of his face. Yesterday, Wednesday morning,
White House spokesman Andrew Bates says, quote,
Since 2008, the president has disclosed his
history with sleep apnea. In medical reports,
he used a CPAP machine last night, which is common
for people with that history. An official familiar
with the matter said. Biden started using the
device in recent weeks to improve sleep quality.
Biden has had a history of sleep apnea in the
past. Sleep apnea is a sleep disorder in which
breathing repeatedly stops and starts. About
30 million people in the United States have
sleep apnea. That's close to 10%. So what
is a CPAP machine? A CPAP CPAP stands for
continuous positive airway pressure. It's a
machine that helps people with sleep apnea
breathe more regularly and consistently while
they are sleeping to prevent those stops and
starts of breathing by delivering a steady flow of
pressurized air. You wear a mask. I know a couple
of people that have this. Now, some people wrote
to me and said, David, you know, sleep apnea can
cause cognitive decline. This may explain what's
going on with Joe Biden. It's really not so much
cognitive decline. But it is true that sleep
apnea, if not controlled, can affect cognitive
function by virtue of the fact that you are not
resting well. If you regularly stop breathing and
have these stops and starts of breathing while
you were sleeping, it affects quality of sleep.
Quality of sleep can affect cognition and memory
and all of those different things. And there are
some studies that show that sleep disordered
breathing, of which sleep apnea is one kind
makes you roughly 26% more likely to develop a
cognitive impairment of some kind versus those
who don't have sleep disordered breathing. So
is this like a huge deal? No, I don't think it's
a huge deal. This is not a new disclosure. It's
just an explanation as to why on this particular
day yesterday, Joe Biden had these marks. We don't
have to. I mean, listen, we don't have to pretend
that Joe Biden is the epitome of youth, vigor and
energy to recognize that there have been a lot of
correct things done under Biden and that given the
opportunity to have either Joe Biden for four more
years or Donald Trump back for four more years,
or Ron DeSantis or whatever, that I would still
pick Joe Biden. It's not you know, I get emails
from people on the right, first of all, saying
you'll never talk about X, Y, Z thing with Biden
like this. Why not? I'm talking about it. There's
really no problem. I don't hide things from my
audience. That's number one. But then number two,
okay, so Joe Biden is sleep apnea and wears a CPAP
machine and he's 80 and he's tripped a couple of
times. You think that means I'm going to elect the
guy who wanted to nuke a hurricane and is accused
of quite literally dozens and dozens of crimes and
did all of the things that Trump did. Of course,
I'm still going to vote for Joe Biden.
Okay. Biden's old and he doesn't have
as much energy and vigor as he did when he was
first Joe Biden. Barack Obama's vice president,
for example. So what? But like what? What's the
big gotcha there? It's not really a big shocker.
So listen, I'll keep you apprized of Joe
Biden's health. And at this point in time,
particularly based on the economic record, it
seems pretty clear who we're better off having
for another four years if the choices are Trump
or Biden or Desanctis and Biden. If you disagree
with me, let me know. And I know many people
do, and I'm perfectly comfortable with that.